Film Courage: What is the first step in writing
a screenplay?
Richard Walter: Getting your butt in the chair
and hands on the keys and seeing where it
goes.
I believe you have to have an outline, but
then you have to throw away that outline.
It will take paths that are surprises to the
artist that created it.
I’ve never known anyone who wasn’t surprised
by lines of dialogue that characters seem
to invent by themselves, twists and turns
in the story.
I remember asking Neil Simon “Do you laugh
at your own jokes?”
And he said “Sure I do, the first time I
hear them.”
And I think that’s fantastic that he actually
hears them.
It’s as if someone else is telling them…telling
these jokes to him.
And that’s the experience of a lot of artists.
I wrote…I sold a TWILIGHT ZONE episode years
and years go about a muse, some sort of composer
of commercial jingles and his muse that proposes…I’ll
spare you the story.
If I told you the story you’d think “Hey,
what a good story!”
But the thesis underneath it was the notion
that muses don’t desert their artists.
It’s really the other way around.
You have to be available.
It’s never easy to get into.
And you have to own that.
And you have to know that.
Not sure that answers What is the First Thing
You Do?
Usually something occurs to you that seems
kind of odd.
Imagined if this happened or that happened?
I remember when our first child was going
to be born we went to birth preparation classes
which were held at Cedars Sinai.
And everybody was supposed to bring a pillow.
So suddenly outside you know, Beverly Blvd.
near San Vincent [in Los Angeles] all of these
couples, all of the women are quite pregnant
and everybody is carrying pillows “What’s
that about?”
Imagine you drive past the bus stop and there
are like 60 people at the bus stop and they
all have accordions.
I don’t know they all have accordions for
some reason.
“What could that be?”
You start to think about that and also you
don’t think about it you just sort of let
it simmer and cook and the notion will come
to you.
And you start to play with it and see how
it unfolds.
I know there are other people, including people
you are talking to I’m sure, who have much
more precise steps.
Well I reject that in my own work and in the
writers that I know.
Again, I think that it’s a function of surprise,
a lot of art is.
And the important thing for the artist is
to stay open to those surprises rather than
trying to drag the narrative back to some
previous intellectual perception that you
had.
The very first script I ever wrote and I never
did sell it (I wrote it in class) like my
own class, except it was cross-town it was
Irwin R. Blacker, legendary teacher of screenwriting,
now long deceased, but he taught George and
Milius and all these people.
And I wrote a story based loosely on a when
I worked on the project, the pilot HEAD START
program, the war on poverty Lyndon B. Johnson
program having to do with support for pre-schoolers
in the schools.
And there was one social worker (a white guy)
advantaged, privileged guy, but he would kind
of speak with kind of a fake black accent,
this street-ey kind of black jive “Hey Bro…wuz
goin’ on?” and he thought that really
impressed the black kids he was working with.
He was not working with preschoolers.
He had started working with adolescents in
another program.
And the establishment, the people who ran
that program thought “Boy this guy really
goes the extra mile!”
I thought he was an idiot!
That he’s just patronizing and condescending.
You know, I’m a jew.
Imagine someone trying to make points with
me in a Yiddish Accent “Richard….”
[imitates a heavy Yiddish accent].
“What a cool guy this is.
He talks the talk!”
Well, this guy got killed.
He was murdered and I thought well that is
something to write a script about.
When I wrote the script, I thought it was
the social worker’s story (the white guy’s
story).
But when I was done, it was really the black
kids story and I didn’t realize this until
I was done with the first draft.
And the smartest thing I did was to leave
it alone in that regard.
That is to say I rewrote it several times
but I let it become the black kids story,
which is a much more interesting story.
The white guy was a subsidiary character now,
not the protagonist of the piece.
I never sold that script but I did get top
representation.
I got assignments.
I got on staff at Universal [Pictures].
A lot of writers don’t get it that when
a script doesn’t sell that’s not the end,
it’s just the beginning.
There are all kinds of rewards that can flow
from a script that doesn’t sell.
Also a script that doesn’t sell now might
sell you know, down the line.
Clint Eastwood made UNFORGIVEN which won the
Oscar for best screenplay, best movie 20 years
after he acquired that script.
So you never really know.
Again, if all the work you put into the first
draft and you end up realizing that the guy
you thought was the protagonist was not the
protagonist (it’s not his story at all),
that’s not a waste.
That shouldn’t be frustrating.
That’s a really good use of that draft.
You’ll salvage some of the stuff in the
draft but also you’ll have used it to point
you in the direction that you need to go.
You can’t figure it out in advance, you
just can’t.
Kushner at the LINCOLN screening…have you
seen it?
Maybe you won’t like it at all but it’s
impossible not to be astonished at how important
it is and engaging it is in the best sense
of important.
And it is a stupendous screenplay by Kushner.
And Tony (Kushner) was saying “A lot of
people think you think the thing up and you
write it down but the writing down of it is
sort of the thinking of it.
There is a nexus between the pen or the keyboard,
or the hands on the keyboard that you just
never know and you have to live with that
uncertainty.
You have to sort of rejoice and celebrate
and face that uncertainty instead of trying
to eliminate the uncertainty.
You look at the studios today and what is
less interesting than what they are doing
now?
They are doing prequels and sequels, items
of franchises.
What they are trying to do is minimize risk.
And they are trying to make it so when an
audience goes to see a movie they get what
they expect.
Well when I go see a movie, I don’t want
to see what I expected.
My expectations should be exceeded.
I want to be turned upside down.
I want to be frightened.
I want life to be changed forever.
It’s funny, I lectured in September a year
ago to an evangelical Christian conference
in Chicago, 500 passengers all across the
nation on narrative and scripture.
I was never more warmly greeted or generously
received.
They also payed me very well.
But I never had a better time, you know.
I’ve given hundreds of speeches all around
the world and I never had a better time than
I had with all these sweet Christians.
And one of the things I told him was if you
wanted to keep people in the Church even after
they leave the Church on Sunday morning…that
is to say…thinking about the sermon just
like after when they leave your movie…I’m
still thinking about LINCOLN and I saw it
over a week ago and it’s still playing in
my head.
And the more time that passes, the more I’m
into it.
It’s not fading, it’s getting stronger.
Maybe I’ll go see it again?
If you want people to stay in the movie, just
like if you want them to stay in the Church,
what I told them was you don’t need to make
people feel good, you just have to make people
feel.
Scare them half to death.
Make them cry, you know?
I remember walking out of the theater and
the doors in Westwood…I was walking down
the street past the theater and the doors
and people started to steam out and it [the
movie] had just broken and I saw somebody
I knew but there were a lot of people between
us and I sort of indicated…we waived hello
and then I pointed to the marquee and shrugged
meaning “So what did you think?”
and at this point he was able to get up to
me and said “….it’s….a….yeah…a
worthy…movie I think you should see.”
And I said like I said to you earlier (and
this does not make me very popular with people
when I tell them what THEY thought of a movie.
Or they tell me what they thought of a movie
and I tell them “No, that’s not what you
thought.
What you thought was such and such.”
I understand that this is pretty arrogant
but what can I tell you?
I’m just reporting honestly, my own reaction.
I said to this guy “I hear you saying it’s
a worthy movie but in my impression it seems
like you didn't like this movie.”
Now I want you to imagine that instead of
the picture breaking and people streaming
out, they are all crying, everybody is sobbing
with tears streaming down their faces.
Well you wouldn’t want to see that movie
would you?
The hell you wouldn’t!
You’d immediately go to see that movie.
You’d stop.
You’d stand up your date or your next appointment
and you’d get in line to see that movie
if it could affect people so strongly.